[Music]
[Applause]
that's a sieve from it chapter 2 the
sequel to the 2017 horror film that was
a hit with critics and audiences alike
it's just one of the many new films
opening in theaters over the next few
months in here with a preview is owen
gleiberman chief film critic for Variety
magazine Owen you're the man with all
the answers let's start with in chapter
2 well they haven't shown most of these
films to us and I'm really looking
forward to seeing this one what was the
first one such a big hit well you know
it's funny people love that Stephen King
novel and the first movie had kind of
stranger things vibe right but at the
same time I think these movies have
become like Freddy Krueger movies and
Pennywise the clown is the new Freddy
and I think that's the hook in the new
one the losers Club has all grown up and
now they're played by people like James
McAvoy and Jessica Chastain that sounds
good to me because those are
tremendously exciting actors but
basically I think this movie is going to
be you know just about the hugest movie
of the fall and that's because it's the
new Freddy
how about Downton Abbey which is so huge
for people to watch now on the big
screen what can we expect yeah well I'm
really excited to see this series coming
back I mean look I have faith in this
movie because it's written by Julian
Fellowes who basically created the
series and in some ways he spun Downton
Abbey out of the movie that he wrote for
Robert Altman in 2001 called Cosford
heart which is a great yeah and look the
whole masterpiece theater genre as we
think of it has kind of hops back and
forth between it started as a television
and then it became Merchant Ivory films
and then the genre kind of faded and
came back with Downton Abbey so it makes
sense to me it feels right that Downton
Abbey now becomes a movie and of course
this one brings back just about all the
cast members right and the king and
queen are coming to the estate visit
that's right Brad Pitt currently on
screening once upon a time in Hollywood
Quentin Tarantino's and hmm he has this
fall the sci-fi epic ad astra what is ad
astra though and Astra is a kind of big
ambitious serious outerspace movie in
which Brad Pitt plays an astronaut who
is sent to Neptune
to retrieve his father who went on a
mission and disappeared like 30 years
before the fathers played by Tommy Lee
Jones and I'm excited to see this movie
because Brad Pitt it's really having a
moment a lot of people think you could
win the Oscar for Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I think he deserves to and I
think he will could he's one of my
favorite actors and so I'm glad to see
Brad Pitt in a big ambitious space movie
never bad to look at that's right a
Martin Scorsese film called the Irishman
mm-hmm tell us more well I think anybody
who loves Martin Scorsese movies and who
does it is excited about seeing the
Irishman it's the talk on this movie is
that it's his big kind of very serious
summing up of the mob John and it's
DeNiro and passion yes that's right
De Niro plays mimics of reality based
drama De Niro plays a hitman who works
for Joe Pesci and Al Pacino let's
Believe It or Not never worked with
Scorsese before plays Jimmy Hoffa and
this is a movie about how Jimmy Hoffa
ended up being assassinated very
possibly by the mob it's three hours
long it's a Netflix movie and there's a
whole drama off screen about where this
movie's going to play which is gonna
play in theatres streaming or in
theaters we don't know that's right we
don't know it's being hammered out but I
think that a lot of people want to see
this movie in theaters so we'll see
we'll see what happened more people in
Detroit are going to the moccasin Fox to
find out if he Hoffa is buried there a
historical epic
Tubman is coming out about Harriet Todd
that's right well it's sort of
astonishing to think that we haven't had
a major movie about Harriet Tubman but
as Hollywood becomes more and more
sensitive to issues of diversity these
kinds of stories that must be told now
can be and this is a very exciting
looking large-scale drama about how
Harriet Tubman escaped from slavery and
then helped hundreds of slaves escape as
well executive producer african-american
woman woman Deborah chase lead actor
Cynthia Revo and also director Casey
lemons that's right it's you who made
Eve's Bayou yes and it's getting a
chance to tell this story which is
fantastic okay that Mister Rogers movie
thanks mr. Rogers yeah well that's all
you need to say right last year there
was you know the terrific documentary
about mr. Rogers and this is kind of
based on that it's about how it's about
his relationship with a journalist
pasted on Tom Juneau and who doesn't
want to see Tom Hanks played mr. Rogers
and I feel like we want to see him that
is as you said enough said yeah Owen
gleiberman thank you so much for the
fall movie preview